thank you
all right bye we're back and for those
of you that came in maybe a little after
five years left because you didn't miss
anything
welcome to the table my name is
[Music]
welcome to those who are watching us
online
[Music]
so let's let's Jump Right In
um
[Music]
foreign
creativity one of my favorite
things I've learned recently is
um that a black woman makes Tina Belle
[Music]
in Seattle
I remember Friends
[Music]
of the time this one and not just for
this one but let it be a springboard
into the rest of the year to learn about
foreign
[Music]
then
uh let's see okay
and that means Ash Wednesday is coming
up and uh this year once again
[Music]
and we will be joining with them for an
Ash Wednesday evening service at 7 pm 7
PM so it should be a beautiful time to
gather with our extended family and uh
[Music]
close your eyes
will be here now
presence
[Music]
our Grace
so God I pray that you would speak to
each one of us whatever it is you have
for us tonight that it would be very
personal that it would be soaked in your
love
and your goodness
that we would remember we're not alone
and then no matter
what each of us walks in here with us
tonight God that we would send us your
presence
Your Love
still enough
and quiet enough
to really bask in that
so God thank you
thank you for denying thank you for this
community in Jesus name amen
[Music]
and I just encourage you to claim this
Hallelujah when you need it in your life
claim it
there is a Hallelujah
[Music]
and I raise a Hallelujah
louder than the I believe
a reason
my weapon is a melody
I raise it Hallelujah
[Music]
comes to fight for me
I'm gonna see
the storm louder and
you're gonna hear
[Music]
death is defeated the king is alive
with everything inside of me
Hallelujah
and I will watch the darkest
[Music]
thank you
needs to hold on
[Music]
hold on
death is defeated the king
[Applause]
[Music]
is
louder and louder
[Music]
the king is alive
little
[Music]
love louder
time
to see a little louder
[Music]
You're Gonna Hear My Praises Roar
Ed
the king is alive
[Music]
foreign
for prisoners
[Music]
and emotional health
Lord we know that you love us yes
[Music]
foreign
Foundation
The Rock only just stand when everything
around me shaking
but I've never been more glad that I put
my faith in Jesus
never let me down it's faithful through
generations
so I would
[Music]
eat more
so I will be
[Music]
let me down
he won't
[Music]
be
love
[Music]
love myself
foreign
[Music]
I'm okay
with
myself
[Music]
foreign
he came with
on you
say
thank you
[Music]
another
cause I'm standing strong
[Music]
foreign
ourselves into you
for ourselves
and in your love
[Music]
could you just take a second to just
open my hands
stretch out your fingers
feel the life
in the lower
from the source of God
[Music]
whatever it is
with you
[Music]
he is
Justice
[Music]
and then thinking about what's going on
if you need this moment
[Music]
there's room for whatever you walk into
this room
[Music]
between you
ready to love you
together
[Laughter]
[Music]
know yourself though you you've only
voices
[Music]
foreign
moving
[Music]
in mind
whatever it is
[Music]
foreign
cause you are complete
please
[Music]
me please hope he says you're mine
smiling
I find it's beautiful
[Music]
my love for you is
he says you're mine
is
beautiful
[Music]
my love for you
I'll come to find would you believe
[Music]
from your presence
around us
[Music]
so much
okay
[Music]
it is so good to be with you all and um
it was beautiful to hear you sing that's
one of the benefits so
[Music]
um
and if you were here
trajectory
[Music]
and um
but at the end of the day
foreign
[Music]
whatever
is right whatever
it is
thinking about such things
tonight
um
[Music]
Amplified
language
[Music]
uh
so all right here again
[Music]
level
today
we live in the age of the image
television Netflix 24 7 News
the written word
[Music]
image and entertainment
and then you're like oh my gosh
foreign
[Music]
like education
a media
when did that happen
right on top of it 500 years ago
the Bible everyone should read the Bible
and we'll have it in a Bible in every
home and can you see where that was part
of the the age of the written word right
um so uh even like politics was hugely
influenced by this like I think of
politicians like a few hundred years ago
here
right like why well because they're
gonna form laws
the whole thing in a newspaper
people would literally read
long
essays of like politicians views arguing
for you know ABC XYZ and so on right can
you see how
it's a different
era now I mean when was the last time
you read like a transcript
of the whole speech that a politician
gave or even if you did the speech it
wouldn't be an Abraham Lincoln's speech
right can you see like honestly for a
long time
um
essays
no
no what's it about we even have a work
for it right like we're a phrase you got
to be able to manage your image it's
about image
right it's about how do they present how
do they come across
and can they kind of be Punchy and short
and quick because they only got about 30
seconds
and better and it better be what above
all in terms of pain
and entertaining
right because you gotta hold
[Music]
work all right
now
um
[Music]
is
like
long arguments like you know things that
require depth and time right because not
everything can be given to you in like
30 seconds or even 30 minutes honestly
you know we're 15 minutes like every TV
show
right right not dependent on what's come
before
right
um
a book in life
the way they used to
5 10 15 20 right
or have you ever found yourself reading
an online article and you have abandoned
it like
500 words
a hundred words in you're like okay I
don't have time for this all right we
gotta we gotta get going here
themselves
[Music]
this is like in other words
for 5 000 here play a game really
education is all a game you know like we
have to kind of drum it up because
everything has to be to this thing
[Music]
it's just
it's a problem
think of how this is
oh I mean I mean
[Music]
like
everything is
everything is becoming Show Business
everything has to be Show Business to to
keep our attention to compete in the age
okay so what on Earth does this have to
do with us and really to reading
scripture
um
is
hungry
so what is it I think
[Music]
um
and it's like
long
and it's like a deep it's talking about
like it requires a knowledge of like
history it's like a long theological
treatment
and then it's letters to people we're
not really familiar with
and it's a poetry who has the time for
poetry
[Music]
oh
slowly
[Music]
the the truth of the Scripture
it is not Unearthed in like 2.7 minutes
it's just not like it is a long slow
processes
it is worth it
it is worth the riches that you start to
receive
d
a reading scripture and Christian
literature they're really talking even
more broadly not just the Bible but also
you know Christian Theology and
devotional literature and all sorts
right the broader tradition
um
[Music]
we begin to flourish because of the
message
[Music]
again my point isn't like entertainment
is evil you know never watch a TV again
[Music]
um
I mean every generation games everyone
had their ways of entertaining
the trouble becomes everything
[Music]
and
um
you know at worst
right it is like
it's it's like I think it's interesting
you know it is
um
right it's sort of at Best in a trivial
and shallow at the worst
with us
does this describe the age of the image
are these the adjectives you'd use
finally brothers and sisters whatever is
true and Noble whatever is right and
pure and lovely and admirable if
anything is excellent or praiseworthy
you know what I think of tick tock Noble
you know excellent
to find
goodness
to nourish our souls
[Music]
instead of going to all that
give me a pause
[Music]
they've produced foreign
is
that with the wicked or stand in the way
that person is like a tree planted by
water which yields
that's nourishing
whatever
don't let it go for two hours
[Music]
stop being a pleaser
says
[Music]
depending on others to give you an
identity
not look at that only in a negative way
you wanted to give your heart to others
so quickly and easily but now you're
being asked to let go of all these a
prop and to trust that God is enough for
you that's preaching someone God is
enough for you you must stop being a
believer
s
[Music]
and who might we become as a community
like what kind of little ones would we
create and make in like if they had
nurse or nourishing themselves
absolutely amazing
so tonight
himself
[Music]
sorry
um
but above the Lord
you have much faith
[Music]
foreign
now
[Music]
let's begin
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
for this
in my eyes
wake me up
she's open my eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
everyday
[Music]
say
that you're good
[Music]
foreign
give you my love
that again
give me
to trust what you say
[Applause]
[Music]
I may be easy
strong in me
[Music]
to trust what you say
that you're good
[Music]
Give Me Faith just trust what you say
that you're good
[Music]
myself
foreign
[Music]
um
hands out
please choose your heart
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and as a true on your worst day
so as we go into your week ahead with
it's yet to be determined highs and lows
with everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to accept these same gifts
of love and grace and compassion
to everyone
[Music]
have a good night
my God
[Music]